hey guys i'm tom oliver from rebel
pixels and tommy oliver TV and today is
one minute monday is money isn't the
only currency how many times along your
journey have you stumbled across the
advice what would you do if money were
no object probably a bunch right and for
good reason because it's completely true
if we're following money instead of our
passion we aren't going to stay
motivated and we're not motivated than
the work either isn't gonna get done
well or even get done at all now why do
we even want money in the first place
it's because it enables something
everything in the world has a price tag
the ability to have anything that we
want and not have to worry about paying
the bills is why we'd be swayed away
from what we really want and get a safe
well-paying boring job but money is the
only thing that can motivate us even if
we decide that we want to pursue
something more meaningful than a
paycheck we can still be swayed by other
types of currency other concepts we
ascribe value to even if it isn't
tangible spendable money for example
fame is a currency everyone wants to be
recognized for what they do and even if
we aren't pursuing money our desire for
fame could be pulling us in a direction
away from our passions so you have to
ask yourself if fame were no object and
everything I did got me equal amounts of
attention what would I do another
currency is effort just like with money
we have to spend our time to create
something and some things are easier
than others our desire for the path of
least resistance will sometimes prevent
us from putting in the time our passion
demands so you need to ask if effort
were no object what would I do and the
interesting thing is when you pick these
desires against each other and to see
where they intersect or conflict and
then try to come to a compromise with
what you covet and what your passions
are if you're like me and you're still
searching for the perfect application of
your passion this exercise can hold a
lot of value believe